hey what's up guys it's marcus brownlee
here from mkbhd and welcome to another
high definition unboxing video and today
we're going to be taking a look at the
motorola droids easy stand this is one
of the first stanzas that came out for
the motorola jury that has been
developed by the company called
easystand so i'm going to do today is
actually just take it out of the box and
give you guys a full tour of the device
and actually go ahead and review it in
the near future
so without any further ado let's get
into this box and show you what comes
inside
so this this uh stand actually does have
a number of interesting features that
this stand i'm currently using doesn't
have uh including magnets and certain
ways that you can position it on the
stand that'll help you out a lot and it
also comes with a lot more than the stan
does
so the first thing you're going to see
in this box is a usb
to what appears to be mini usb
usb data transfer cable that normally
comes with your droid
and the next thing you have in here is
the easy stand itself so i'm going to go
ahead and put that right there what
we're going to do is actually just take
a look at the stand since we
got it out here in this quick unboxing
video
it's a really very simple stand you can
see it's just plain black like the one
i'm using but it's a little bit larger
and it'll actually serve a number of
more awesome purposes
so here you can see on the front there's
this nice very thick texture velvety
substance it's kind of tacky actually in
a good way time that sticks holds on
your desk there's also that tacky
substance on the bottom so i can't
really move it i'm applying a lot of
pressure and i just can't move it
so
probably wondering how does the droid
actually fit on the stand right here
and this is the primary way that your
droid is going to fit on the stand there
are magnets in the left hand side and
the right hand side so if i just pull
this into view here
that will actually activate
the
the night mode for the motorola droid so
as you can see it just turned on there
this stand that i'm using right now
happens to be extremely simple has a
couple of foam tips it isn't very
functional so i'll move this off to the
side
but yeah this is the basic essence of
the actual stand if you want more
information you can visit the link in
the description uh for the easy stand
website this is actually an actually
clever way to use your droid while it's
on your nightstand and it'll serve as my
alarm clock mode and a number of things
but you'll be able to see all the full
features of this stand when i do review
it in the near future so until then
thanks for watching this quick unboxing
video and i'll talk to you guys in the
next one peace